[Music]
I understand that since the law was
passed by the council and came into
operation but the vehicles on the beach
have gone down considerably you really
see a vehicle on the beach now so you
know people are really buying into it
and already we're seeing an improvement
so yeah it's been good it will carry on
you know we have to carry on to keep
keeping word up and not let it black so
that goes back to what it was like yes
and I think it's a lost in cannabis
ranges that are probably most important
volunteers explaining an educated give
information out that there's lots of
other groups we have Wizards
associations or community board or
whatnot but we have to support them we
show some of that burden them and feed
that information out into the sort of
networks that we we've got a consultant
each other and talk with each other and
come to an arrangement that works for
everybody and I think that's the
implementation process is what that's
about
there's a conversation in trying to work
out how we can all exist coexist
together to the harmony of all I agree
and if they are getting all in users buy
into to it benefit
let's resonate on just how special this
area is and when we forget each of us
talking about things that we see as
being what it is that was a very very
special area upon its present in the
part of that is educating all
regressions is about specialness to
needs of everyone rebuttal the hell with
it
you